- [Narrator] This is
the Texas horned lizard,
a species which happens to be
the official state reptile,
and you know what they
say, “Don't Mess With Texas.”
(gentle music)
The Texas horned lizard is aptly named
because of its numerous horns.
The most prominent horns
are the two central ones
located at both the center
and rear of the skull.
Frequently preyed upon by other animals,
its distinct coloration allows it
to camouflage itself amongst vegetation.
But when hunted by creatures
such as snakes, coyotes, and hawks,
they can either inflate to a larger size
or flatten in order to
blend in with the ground.
However, their best and more
unique defense against prey
is their ability to shoot a
stream of blood from its eyelid,
directly into the enemy's eyes.
The Texas horned lizard's population
has dropped dramatically in recent years
due to the state's rapid urbanization,
leaving them with a shrinking habitat.
This is the Texas horned lizard.